today i'm going to demonstrate a simple
way to plug the end of a header pipe
plug in the end of a lay flat header
pipe is quick easy and necessary for the
irrigation setup
there are various sizes of late flat
header pipe to choose from for this
reason be sure to double check that your
connector fitting and plug are the same
diameter as the pipe you are using we
are using a two inch pipe and two inch
fittings sometimes it is possible to
find a one piece plug but we have found
them hard to find locally so in this
video we are using a couple different
fittings to make a plug
we wrap teflon tape around the white
threaded cap screwed it into the gray
bar fitting and tighten it with a pipe
wrench
once you have the cap ready place the
clamp on the lathe pipe
next put the barb cap inside the end of
the pipe this part can be a little
tricky so gently twist and push the
connector in until the pipe is snug
against the connector fitting
another option is to put a full grade
lubricant like vaseline or vegetable oil
on the outside of the connector so it
slides on the pipe more easily
push the clamp to the top of the fitting
and using a flat head screwdriver
tighten the clamp now you are ready to
attach the drip tape to the header pipe
we hope this video was very useful
please check out our video series to
learn all the steps in installing a
simple irrigation system on a small
phone thank you
you